je me pose
[Musique]
c'est évidemment une parodie est la
traduction n'a absolument rien à voir
avec les propos tenus par vladimir
poutine avant la guerre andrei était
tailleur de pierre aujourd'hui même
s'ils risquent tous les jours la mort il
ne veut pas abandonner
avec des voisins il a décidé de
reconstruire sa maison et malgré l'enfer
qu'il traverse il n'a pas perdu son sens
de l'humour je peux dire merci à poutine
grâce à lui on a plein de bois
direction maintenant la russie où un
détenu incarcéré pour vol décide de
profiter de son petit gabarit pour se
frayer un chemin vers la liberté
un exploit qui sera capturée par les
images de vidéosurveillance du couloir
de la prison
[Musique]
toi
4 2
sur cette séquence on peut voir l'homme
complètement nu passer à travers la
trappe de nourriture de sa cellule
une fois dans le couloir il sera bénie
tranquillement avant de se diriger vers
la sortie
à ce jour il n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé en anatomie comment
appelle-t-on couramment l'ombilic
ils ont qu'à réglages ou calcul le ver
de terre mais
l'ombilic
en anatomie
en termes de chirurgie donc j'ai refait
messin trois fois mon âge et mes fesses
deux fois et pour l'élève là savent tous
les 6 mois voilà le botox et moi c'est
une histoire d'amour bon je pense que
vous l'avez remarqué à la vache a fait l
robocup de la chirurgie esthétique en
fait tu le rebond quote tu te
dégradables et ma chérie si tu as le
compte en banque et la carte bleue pour
pierre plaisir c'est le très loin du
métro boulot dodo je vous propose 80
secondes image internationale totalement
dépaysante pour vous présenter ces
influenceurs voyage au corps d'éphèbe
qui ont tout quitté sur un coup de tête
pour nous narguer en postant des photos
d'eux avec l'air de nous dire est
regardé comme en osier trop génial par
rapport à la vôtre à lévis mme laga et
ben moi j'ai démarré de minuit à 4
heures du matin voilà avec jean luc
mélenchon y aller mais quand même je le
sais
le autant premier patron de radio
c'était jean luc mais justement ça
n'empêchait pas bien il est là
jean luc mélenchon et comme je le disais
toujours est il était patron d'une radio
qui s'appellera douleur essonne et je
travaillais là bas et à l'époque ça
faisait pas chier de me faire travailler
le dimanche gratos
travail c'est la santé
un faire c'est la conserver
je suis vraiment une femme d'affaires on
va dire mais à ce moment là je perds mes
affaires synchronicité de l'ami fait que
je perds mes affaires pour différentes
raisons et là je sens que quelque part
tout s'écroule en fait comme je donne
naissance à sept enfants mais en même
temps tout s'écroule au pad et vous à
faire votre sac vous voulez dire non
mais le business business
les quatre blocs à la place ce qui va
suivre et sans trucage et sa foi un
petit coup à la crédibilité du propos
c'est très bien que dans notre propre
pipe dans tous les pays
européen mais qu' on est dissuadé de le
faire donc nous laissons pas
impressionner évidemment moi j'ai fait
beaucoup et envoie les attentats
et oignons
l'ail
ces jeunes migrants ces mineurs isolés
n'ont rien à faire ici ils sont voleurs
ils sont assassins il son violeur c'est
tout ce qu'ils sont ces mots d'eric
zemmour condamné en janvier dernier pour
provocation à la haine j'imagine que
vous rendre fou oui c'est pitoyable
je comprends que ce journaliste écrivain
raté
veille son heure de gloire en
déplacement à moissac dans le tarn et
garonne eric zemmour accompagné de
marion maréchal a été victime d'un
lancer de 9,7 à priori le père d'un
enfant handicapé qui lui aurait écrasé
le projectile sur la tête un homme
aussitôt maîtrisé et emmené par les
gendarmes eric zemmour ne portera pas
plainte il a même demandé à discuter
avec son agresseur avant de sibérie
souffle sur la bohème les femmes sont en
colère aux portes des moulins
puisqu'aucun dieu du ciel ne s'intéresse
à nous lénine relève toi ils sont
devenus fous
toi vladimir ilic tu as raison tu
rigoles toi qui a voyagé dans un wagon
plombé
[Applaudissements]
allez
vous
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu tiens est ce que l'amour
peut être inconditionnel
oui oui il existerait vous avez un chien
votre chien vous aime d'un amour
inconditionnel ça c'est vrai parce que
quand tu mets ton chien dans un coffre
trouve le coffre il va être retenue
alors que tu fais ça
[Rires]
depuis plus de 25 ans elle partage son
toit et sa vie sentimentale avec
d'autres polyamoureux attention on peut
s'y perdre vous êtes prêts en plus de
head qui vit d'ailleurs valérie a une
histoire avec le maître de maison ken
monsieur lui est en couple avec jodie et
entretient aussi une relation avec paigc
sacrée organisation au quotidien alors
pas d'autre choix que de synchroniser
les agendas vous avez trouvé un truc
malin en fait pour être rajeuni vous
mais
je vais le faire parce que c'est quoi le
truc la différence c'est que vous êtes
de plus en plus beau
cela dit
et
thierry ardisson est de plus en plus on
va sexuelle
c'est pas faux
non non non je vous dirai pas la femme
regarde
le peg elle passe la journée du 2 avec n
moi c'est le 4 encore faibles cet émoi
le dise je suis poli saturé j'arrive au
maximum de mes capacités je pense que ça
marche il soit y avoir quelques soucis
de la confusion des incompréhensions
jusqu'ici il n'y a pas eu de gros
problèmes
voilà ça y est
le message était bien il était à voilà
message
[Musique]